[Música]
Bienvenidos a un nuevo episodio de
boleto de vuelta que en esta ocasión nos
lleva a las Islas malvinas un
archipiélago que ha estado en medio de
una disputa histórica entre los
británicos y los argentinos que terminó
por transformarse en un conflicto armado
hace 40 años las Islas malvinas que Gran
Bretaña llama Las se sitúan en el Océano
Atlántico a 400 kilómetros de las costas
de Argentina han tenido varias oleadas
de colonización incluida una por los
franceses pero fueron los británicos
quienes las ocuparon definitivamente en
1833 el archipiélago es un territorio
británico de ultramar pero Argentina
estando tan cerca a reivindicado en las
islas desde su independencia en 1816
pero no fue hasta 1982 que estalló la
guerra en esa época el jefe de la junta
en el poder en Argentina Leopoldo
galtieri ordenó a sus tropas invadir las
Islas malvinas pero la primera ministra
británica margaret thatcher decidió
inmediatamente enviar su ejército para
retomar las foodlands el conflicto sólo
duró 10 semanas y terminó con la
rendición de las tropas argentinas
murieron 649 argentinos 255 británicos y
tres habitantes de la isla las
relaciones diplomáticas entre Buenos
Aires y Londres Se restablecieron en
1990 pero la posición de ambos países
sobre las malvinas no ha cambiado Esta
es la historia
[Música]
nunca perdonado y jamás lo haré nunca le
daré la mano un argentino mientras no
hayan renunciado a las
[Música]
aquí la población quiere ser británica
siempre ha querido serlo no quiere ser
Argentina
[Música]
sigue reclamando las Islas lo que el
gobierno argentino trata de hacer es
colonizar las focklands
en contra de la voluntad de sus
habitantes de su población
un archipiélago rocoso situado en los
confines del Atlántico Sur sobre el que
dos países discuten sin tregua hasta el
punto de darle dos nombres diferentes
las forelands de un lado del océano las
malvinas del otro
en Argentina se dice que solo dos temas
unen a toda la población Maradona y la
reivindicación de las Islas
algunos incluso deciden llevar las
grabadas en la piel
siempre de pequeño sentí el tema este de
malvinas
tomé la decisión de hacerlo por una
cuestión de
sentirlo
pasa por acá por la piel por la sangre
es como
van a pasar 40 más y vamos a seguir
recordándola siempre
que hoy en día básicamente es algo
clásico no del tatuaje en Argentina es
algo icónico a las malvinas siempre
están independiente de la generación que
viene mucha gente joven que ni siquiera
había nacido en la época de la guerra
más de ocho de cada diez argentinos
consideran que su gobierno debe seguir
reclamando la soberanía sobre las Islas
La derrota de 1982 frente a los ingleses
todavía es una herida abierta en el país
649 argentinos perdieron la vida durante
el conflicto es duro enfrentarse a los
nombres exactos Y ya y ellos no pudieron
volver como tuvimos la suerte algunos de
devolver no Martín otanio tenía 18 años
cuando fue enviado para combatir en las
malvinas
El joven soldado acababa de empezar su
servicio militar
a nosotros no nos dio tiempo de
entrenarnos Vale pero no solo a disparar
sino que Tampoco sabía nada de
comunicaciones nadie me había enseñado a
usar una radio ni nada me sentía como
que era Carne de cañón igual que el
siete de cada diez combatientes eran
jóvenes reclutas menores de 20 años
después de dos meses y medio de
enfrentamientos los argentinos se
rindieron ante el ejército de margaret
thatcher pero el calvario de Martín
continuó como habíamos perdido la guerra
éramos como una vergüenza nos trajeron a
escondidas de noche y nos metieron de
nuevo en el cuartel no dejaron que nadie
nos recibiera Para mí fue casi más
doloroso que que todo lo que viví en
Durante los dos meses y medio que estuve
en las malvinas encerré todo eso que me
había pasado en una especie de cajoncito
dentro de mi alma y ahí lo guardé con
una llave y tiré la llave a Martín le
tomó más de 30 años y un largo exilio en
España para poder volver a hablar sobre
las malvinas
sin ningún acompañamiento más de 400
soldados argentinos se suicidaron
Durante los meses siguientes a la guerra
pero con el paso de los años esos
recuerdos vergonzosos de la derrota se
fueron borrando y han sido reemplazados
por un fuerte patriotismo
en el centro del país con motivo de los
40 años de la guerra se hace una
ceremonia para celebrar el coraje de los
pilotos argentinos la fuerza aérea
orgullosa de su estirpe de su historia
de su gesta
Graciela Cabrera perdió a su esposo
durante el conflicto
orgullosa de que siempre hay gente que
moviliza para mantener vivo el reclamo
hacia nuestra soberanía en algún momento
quizás diplomáticamente pueda pueda
volver a flamear la bandera Argentina en
la isla malvinas
[Música]
Graciela conservó las fotos de esa época
sobre todo por su hija Andrea que tenía
un año cuando murió su padre
en el campo de bolsa fue el día que que
foba preparar la valija para irse a un
13 de abril de 1982
después no lo volvemos a ver más fue un
año muy duro no quiero hablar
Bahía la cara de él en cada rostro
porque yo no sabía si estaba
desaparecido si estaba muerto
yo me siento totalmente orgullosa sea 40
años 10 50 lo siento voy a sentirme
siempre orgullosa de ellos de todos los
que volvieron y los que no
llegó el tiempo en que en que sean
reconocidos
Eso me alegra Porque mucha gente nos no
sabía nada
partimos en dirección el archipiélago de
las malvinas
[Música]
a menos de 500 kilómetros de las costas
argentinas también es época de
conmemoraciones
[Música]
en el pueblo de good Green antes de la
intervención del ejército británico más
de una centena de habitantes fueron
retenidos como Rehenes por los
argentinos en este recinto
Así vivíamos en esta habitación cuando
estábamos todos encerrados tomé esta
foto para recordarlo
mi mujer y yo dormíamos ahí al lado de
la puerta habíamos cavado guaridas
debajo del suelo cuando se
intensificaban los combates podíamos
refugiarnos debajo de los cimientos
era el responsable de la colonia gusgri
sus recuerdos traumáticos de la guerra
todavía lo acompañan 40 años después
nunca perdonado y jamás perdonaré he
estado dos veces en las Naciones Unidas
me he encontrado con argentinos y les he
dicho que nunca le daré la mano un
argentino mientras no hayan renunciado a
la reivindicación de nuestras Islas
en el archipiélago la guerra marcó a los
habitantes y también dejó huellas en el
paisaje
sobre todo reforzó el sentimiento de
pertenencia al Reino Unido
pienso que realmente estamos muy
orgullosos de pertenecer a la familia
británica y somos muy Patriotas Así que
van a ver muchas banderas también
conducimos por la izquierda siempre ha
sido así claro menos cuando las Islas
estaban ocupadas en este momento los
argentinos nos obligaron a conducir del
otro lado Leona Roberts tenía 10 años
durante la época de la guerra su familia
hace parte de los primeros británicos
que se instalaron en el archipiélago
de lado a mi madre y mi familia llegó
aquí en 1841 entonces hay nueve
generaciones de nuestra familia en la
isla yo soy la sexta
Nick es la séptima somos una familia muy
arraigada aquí en 2013 se llevó a cabo
un referendo en el archipiélago para
preguntarle a los habitantes si querían
seguir perteneciendo al Reino Unido al
igual que Leona y su hijo Nick el 99,8%
de los habitantes votaron pero el
escrutinio fue considerado ilegítimo por
Argentina
los argentinos dicen que somos una
población de colonos lo que no tiene
ningún sentido aquí no había
prácticamente nada cuando llegó mi
familia
nosotros construimos este país
entonces decirnos que no existimos que
mis hijos no tienen derecho a la
autodeterminación me parece ofensivo
la atención es con Argentina no han
disminuido en especial Durante los
últimos 30 años el archipiélago se ha
convertido en un territorio muy próspero
con más de 440 millones de dólares de
ahorros
para entender De dónde viene ese dinero
hay que ir a la cocina de un restaurante
aquí está la riqueza de las Islas
este es nuestro calamar local que está
precortado
le añadimos un poco de chile por encima
un tesoro del mar muy famoso en el
archipiélago y en el mundo entero esto
sabe a las focklands
chery Roberts dirige una Pescadería
en cada caja se puede ver la talla
también está la fecha donde fue pescado
y congelado unos años después de la
guerra Reino Unido estableció una zona
de pesca exclusiva alrededor de las
focklands desde entonces los navíos
extranjeros deben pagar impuestos lo que
ha cambiado radicalmente la vida de los
habitantes la pesca representa el 64% de
nuestro pib lo que permite financiar el
acceso a una educación gratuita y una
atención médica gratuita Entonces es
extremadamente importante Tratamos de
hablar con Cherry acerca de la opinión
de Argentina sobre esos importantes
recursos marítimos no se puede decir que
nos estamos aprovechando de la situación
Porque son nuestras Islas nuestras aguas
nuestros peces ellos no nada que decir
al respecto Sin embargo a los argentinos
les sobran argumentos
en la capital Buenos Aires el museo
malvinas expone todas las razones por
las cuales el archipiélago sería
suramericano
con este esqueleto de un elefante Marino
del sur vamos que con las mismas
especies las que van de malvinas a el
continente ida y vuelta uniendo estos
territorios que son parte del mismo
hábitat malvinas es la Patagonia misma
cada día unos mil estudiantes descubren
aquí los vínculos entre su país y las
Islas este pueblo se empieza a formar en
realidad en 1820
era un pueblo en el que escuchen bien se
festejaba el 25 de mayo se cantaba el
himno tomaba mate los ingleses
aprovechan la oportunidad para usurpar
las Islas malvinas el tres de enero de
1833 expulsan a la población
lo más importante es que todo que tengan
argumentos para defender la soberanía
Argentina sobre las Islas que sepan las
cosas geográficas históricas jurídicas
para que desde todos los puntos de vista
sepan defender esta causa tan importante
para los argentinos aunque esta joven
generación aún no había nacido cuando se
produjo la guerra el tema de las
malvinas está en el centro de sus
preocupaciones espero que algún día en
el Reino Unido reconozca la soberanía
Argentina sobre las malvinas y estaría
muy bueno poder ir a visitarlo como
Argentina
el pintor Javier de abuison tampoco ha
estado en las malvinas
[Música]
en 1982 se salvó durante el sorteo y no
tuvo que hacer su servicio militar
pero sí amigos míos estuvieron eso es
muy fuerte porque un número hace que
puedas estar o no en la guerra un número
hace que pueda cambiar tu vida
y con la Cruz Roja Internacional uno de
sus amigos de infancia que sí vivió la
guerra es el combatiente Martín que ya
habíamos conocido desde el frente El
joven soldado le envió una carta a
Javier esa correspondencia fue El Punto
de partida para la próxima exposición
del pintor para conmemorar los 40 años
del conflicto
y apareció entre un montón de fotos no Y
dije qué mejor que que hace un trabajo
donde donde puedas subyacer la carta
dentro de imágenes hecho esta puestas no
como la muerte la violencia las
explosiones el desamparo Para mí fue muy
liberador y
fue como una catarsis no
revivir y sentir esas emociones tanto
tiempo olvidadas o escondidas lo que sea
yo creo que el arte en este caso cumplió
la función de sanar
de reencontrar y de comprender
hoy se inaugura la exposición de Javier
el artista tiene una sorpresa para
Martín invitó a sus amigos de infancia
que el veterano no había vuelto a ver
desde la guerra cuando cortó los
vínculos con su vida anterior
por favor
[Aplausos]
Estos son algunos de mis compañeros del
colegio
40 años fuimos juntos al colegio Sí es
increíble bueno todo el proceso con
Javier desde el reencuentro de la carta
el reencuentro entre nosotros mismos
todo se cierra y se se encaja de nuevo y
sí estamos muy contentos por eso
la guerra se paró nuestra amistad pero a
través del arte también a la historia de
la guerra nos unió Este es el momento de
concreción de eso
40 años después finalmente Se cerraron
las heridas individuales
pero la nación Argentina no está lista
para cicatrizar ni renunciar a las islas
del Atlántico Sur
[Música]
Gracias por acompañarnos en esta edición
de boleto de vuelta que en esta
oportunidad nos llevó a las Islas
malvinas visitamos el archipiélago tras
cuatro décadas de conflicto un conflicto
que parece no tener fin Recuerden que
puede Ingresar a nuestra página web
France 24.com para ver esta emisión y
las anteriores Hasta pronto
[Música]